hello there i'm gav welcome to this
slower guys video this one
is sponsored by mio it's a water
enhancer that when you squirt into a
nice cup of water you get a very
visually appealing
colorful flume reminiscent of our ink in
the water video from a few years ago
today we'll be taking inspiration from
that and recreating a classic science
experiment
replacing the glass of water with this
massive tank and dropping
molten thermite into it recording it
obviously
at over a thousand frames a second in 4k
the next thing i'm going to do is get
into some safety gear
and tell you not to try this at home i
don't really know how you would though
this here is our lovely pot of thermite
whenever i ask the question
how bright is thermite the answer seems
to be yes
so what we're going to do is a small
test i'm going to learn a lot about how
bright it is
what i should be exposing for currently
i'm an f8
on a 90 degree shutter at a thousand
frames a second so let's see how bright
this truly is
okay as you can see thermite is indeed
very bright completely blown out at an
f8
so for this next shot i exposed uh f16
to the point where it looks like this
was filmed at night even though it's a
bright sunny day
and only now am i seeing any information
in those molten blobs
what we're using here is the most common
combination of materials to make
thermite and that is very finely ground
up
aluminium and iron oxide which is
pretty much just rust powder
um
we've learned a lot of good things from
the test i'm happy with my exposure iso
320
90 degree shutter f16
unheard of f-stop for me doing this the
thermite will melt through this pot
go into the water the sand will
hopefully stop it from melting through
the bottom of the tank this is a plastic
tank
that is slightly leaking so not sure how
many goes we'll get from this tank
this footage is actually slightly
different to
footage of if you're just pouring molten
metal into water if you've ever seen
that you'll notice that as the
molten liquid descends it cools down it
becomes more red and eventually
sort of just stacks up as solid metal in
the bottom the thermite
the reaction continues all the way down
it remains molten even after it lands on
the sand
the reaction here isn't actually using
any oxygen from the surrounding air and
it's not creating co2
as a byproduct what we're doing is
transferring the oxygen from the iron
oxide to the aluminium
and that is a massive exothermic
reaction
the two reaction products that we're
left with which is just plain old iron
and aluminium oxide
end up over 2000 degrees celsius
hence the brightness
slightly different effect when it lands
in water there's a lot of extra bubbles
and
gump coming out along with the thermite
so in order to see a little bit more of
that
i'm just going to expose for for the sky
so this will be
very bright thermite but you'll be able
to see everything around it
[Music]
so we know that this reaction is just a
direct transfer between the two
materials involved
and it's not creating any gases as a
byproduct so the bubbles are actually
just a result of the insane temperatures
immediately flashing the surrounding
water to steam
and especially in this shot on the right
you can see the insane amount of steam
bubbles being produced by
the heat of the molten thermite
the water itself doesn't actually quench
the reaction so you kind of just have to
wait it out
and at the end you're just left with
very brittle pieces of iron
well i think we've got all the shots
that i wanted to see some lovely looking
footage however slight problem
we do have 10 pounds of thermite left
over
that i don't really want to take home so
we just put it in a tin can and we're
just going to get rid of it all at once
for reference everything we've done so
far has been no bigger than three pounds
you need quite a lot of heat to start
this thermite reaction the little thing
you're seeing sticking out the side of
the can there is a small
magnesium strip
it's honestly a lot going on here you
can see the the thermal reaction has
started but
a lot of the powder has fallen under the
water and is now exploding back
out like a volcano
interestingly if i wind it back look at
how quickly
the side of this can becomes molten
so the reaction has just started once
all these sparks clear out of the way
just around where it's being held in
place it's already glowing so in
in real time that is around a third of a
second
that this can became liquid basically
causing it just to give up and fall in
well i think we've ended up with some
wonderful artsy looking footage there
very satisfying to look at i could watch
that for ages
now i'd love to tell you about the
sponsor of this video mio and
as you listen to me please enjoy these
lovely slow-mo clips
of me squeezing some mio into some water
mio may be small but it packs a mighty
punch with a cheeky little squeeze
you can add some incredibly bold flavors
to your water
you can see me here blasting a few of
them in and you'll be glad to know
every mio flavor is zero calories
you do have to drink quite a lot of
water every day to stay properly
hydrated so if you've grown
bored of the flavorless taste of water
mio is pretty perfect for adding to each
glass
and encouraging you to drink your full
recommended amount of water every day
very pretty colors very satisfying to
look at big thanks to mio for sponsoring
this video if you want to get hold of
some yourself there's a link in the
description
and big thanks to you for watching this
video make sure you subscribe
and we've got a second channel if you
wish i'll see you next time